please be with you welcome to the DS
show subscribe if you haven't already
now in this episode of the DS show we're
going to be talking about problem Ahamed
peace and blessings be upon him when
someone enters Islam Islam is simply an
Arabic word which means to surrender and
submit to the crater alone to worship
God Almighty not the creation and then
you also agree that Muhammad peace be
upon him was indeed the final Messenger
of God this would automatically include
not exclude all the preceding messengers
that came before him including Jesus
Noah Abraham Moses and all the other
messages that God sent to guide out of
his love humanity with the same message
worship the one God the Creator not his
creation how can you be assured that
Muhammad was a messenger who was this
this man that so many has written about
and there's no other human being that
life has been more authentically
recorded at his life so we're going to
be talking about this on this episode of
the Deen show because we got to figure
it out now before death comes what's the
purpose of life why we're here and in
Islam we have all those clear answers
but how can you be sure that indeed
Islam is from the Creator we got to
examine this man's life we'll be right
back with more Hannah being show don't
go anywhere
[Music]
he'll Salam alaikum wa alaikum Salam how
are you doing good below yourselves good
to have you back on the Deen show is
that a look at my plate all the way from
algae Australia Australia the house is
there the Aussie is there hamdulillah
now tell us when I open up the program I
talked about we had to examine the life
of problem hundred peace be upon him
because there is a message there we want
to look at the messenger see if his life
evaluated and you can in contrast
because he came with the Quran so you
can know indeed is the Quran what's his
motive did he do this for money for
paying for power or ZD the messenger fee
so you can call it's one man making a
claim so you could put them on the
witness stand and evaluate his life in
contrast to for instance the Bible you
have an animus both return out to to
insult anybody or disparage anybody but
if you want to do the same with the
Bible for instance you have a lot of an
animus honestly it cannot do the same
thing is this correct - that's right
here so that's why we want to it's in
human beings nature to acknowledge
there's only one God worship to create
an equation but the other part of accept
Islam is to agree that Muhammad is the
Messenger of God how could we be sure of
this show very important question so
let's go in different segments 0.01
we'll see what does Quran say about
Prophet Muhammad then we will see what
does the other faith to speak about a
person like this Prophet Muhammad and
then we'll see the secular sources such
as encyclopedia and other great scholars
of other faiths or even people with no
faith or have they got to say about
Prophet Muhammad when they studied or
read through his his biography and this
will give Audrina a very clear picture
of what he is and what he is not now
point number one on most of our analysis
to the Muslims in the Quran in surah
al-e-imran
for the number 3 animal 31 how do we
learn a shape on regime will income come
to head Boonen laa
factor Baroni yes big common law where
silicon duro welcome or not a fedora he
lost valance Allah commands the Muslims
and faith to the prophets allah o allah
say to them pull in kuntum to hit
bounnam mark that if you love God if you
love Allah factor only then obey me then
follow me your big common law in return
Allah the Almighty God will love you
will absolutely no control over come and
forgive you your sins
la foto rahim allah is oft-forgiving
most merciful
there is not any sin in Islam if someone
repent Allah will not forget there is
not a single sin like that and lot is
very merciful and very graceful now
let's see what Allah is saying about
Prophet Muhammad he's saying if you love
God you go to obey the Prophet if I was
late at the time of Moses and I believe
in one God who would I have to believe
in to believe in that one God I would
have to believe in Moses I can't say
standing in front of Moses saying I
believe in one God but I don't believe
in you I would not be a Jew at the time
she can't bypass man you can't bypass
Moses and then I come across the time of
Jesus and this is where the Jews have
gone wrong in theological aspect they
said I believe in Moses and I believe in
God but I reject Jesus so what happens
according to Christianity rejecting
Jesus is wrong
that's what even Muslims say so if you
say I believe in one God but I if you
stand in front of Jesus you say to him I
believe in one God
I love Moses but I reject you you're
gone you're making a mistake
similarly at this time now you can't say
I believe in one God
I love Moses I love Jesus but I reject
Muhammad because the moment you reject
the prophet of God at that time I've
actually rejected the entire concept of
God if LOM is not claiming Muhammad
peace be upon him is the only prophet
and either this plan is actually
claiming Prophet Muhammad is the last
prophet as mentioned in surah as up for
the number 33 animal 4000 hasta maana B
and he's the last topic let's now see
what a lot of analysis to Muslims
regarding Prophet Mohammed who is
Prophet Muhammad for Muslims Allah says
in the Quran in various places up to
Allah a few of us holy obey Allah and
obey the Prophet and this is same
exactly for Jesus he's the light the
truth for the people of his time so
Prophet Muhammad he has to be the
prophet of his time so message a film La
Jolla pure soul obey Allah and obey the
traffic now this is mentioned in the
Quran in great detail it's mentioned in
surah al Imran chapter number 3 verse
number 32 Suleiman chapter number 3
verse number 132 so then he said chapter
number 4 verse 59
surah nisa chapter number 4 verse 69
it's mentioned in surah my the chapter
number 5 verse number 72
it's further mentioned in surah new
chapter in my 24 verse number 52 as well
in surah mohammed civil 47 i number 33
and so that the law 464 i number 12 in
all these different places Allah
commands in the Quran you have to obey
Allah the Almighty and you have to obey
the Prophet let us now see what further
Prophet Muhammad said about Billy
and following him he said in the famous
hadith sahih al-bukhari William number
nine had this number 251 and at least
number 384 is that all my followers will
enter paradise except the one who
refuses to enter and the companions are
so prophet of Allah who would refuse
from entering paradise the Prophet said
anyone who obeys me with enter paradise
anyone who disobeys me will refuse from
entering paradise
so the equation in Islam is very simple
and clear you believe in one God and you
obey that God and you obey the prophet
of that time if you obey the Prophet and
obey God you're into paradise you don't
obey the Prophet you're not obeying God
and you don't enter paradise the
equation is simple as that now what if
someone are our brothers our humanity
the Christians they say look there's a
lot of false prophets that came and they
mentioned Joseph Smith for instance what
what did you think
yes and I'll see let's go to the Bible
and see what Bible says about a future
coming prophet and this is very
important it goes into the Bible in the
Old Testament book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 18 verse number 18 it
says God says to Moses I will raise them
up a prophet from among their brethren
like unto thee like unto you he will not
speak by himself but all that I shall
command him to speak now this prophecy
Christians generally claim this is
dangerous
but you can understand the word is
saying I will raise them up a profit so
if they agree this was Jesus but he
gotta agree Jesus is only the Prophet my
god second it makes you a clear
distinction that it can be Jesus because
the word is saying from among their
brethren so this is the Jewish community
the Israelites and God is saying this
prophet will be from your brethren
meaning from your cousins the cousins of
Jews the whole world knows are the Arabs
all right whatever you know issues we
have it between us resolve it but this
is between the cousins the Arabs and the
Jews are the children of Isaac and a
smile both were children of Abraham
Abraham so both are cousins so God is
saying they will be from among the
cousins so it has to be no one else
other than the Arab prophet among the
Arabs after each mine peace be upon me
smile on Islam there was no other
prophet other than Prophet Muhammad so
it has to be Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him it goes further in book of Song
of Solomon chapter 5 verse 16 it
mentions the name jicama mr. Kim Vakula
Muhammed in the translation reads
he is altogether lovely his mouth is
sweet
yes we agree Prophet Muhammad is
altogether lovely but you don't
translate the knowledge so the word
feeds
jicama mr. Kim we could no Mohammed Amin
ym in Hebrew that respect is added by
adding M below Elohim Mohammed Mohammed
bin so even the name Muhammad is still
there in the original manuscript of
Hebrew language of the Bible in Song of
Solomon
so in song the sound Mohammed peace be
upon his name is mentioned mention there
lissa how could you get away from it
let's stop there take a break and right
back with more here in the D show don't
go anywhere back here on the D show so
we're giving our brothers humanity the
Christians who look to the Bible for
guidance they can reflect over these
bodies these verses from the Bible to
see that there was a messenger coming
after he Jesus it's not talking about
the Joseph Smith wearing a lot of like
definitely not get pretty clear you also
even have Muhammad peace be fine name in
the song the solid 5 verse 16 give us
something else to show the flood so we
go further into the New Testament not in
the words of Jesus peace be upon him
there are verses where Jesus speaks
about another comforter prophet or
helper coming in the future this was
mentioned in the Bible in great detail
in Gospel of John chapter 14 verse 16
Gospel of John chapter 14 verse 26 to 28
Gospel of John chapter 15 verse 26
Gospel of John chapter number 1 verses
19 to 21 Gospel of John chapter number 1
was in the 25 book of Judith chapter
number 1 verse number 14 as well we will
see in some of the works of in detail
Jesus is saying Jesus is asked a
question by the Jews and but even to
John the Baptist so the Jews are waiting
for three people
and they asked John the Baptist and
Gospel of John chapter 1 verses 19 to 21
they asked him are you the elijah the
elias
he says no they say are you the Christ
John the Baptist says no they say are
you that prophet you see there are three
distinct personalities Jews were waiting
according to the Old Testament
the one is the Elijah the alias which is
actually John the Baptist the second is
the Christ the Messiah that is Jesus
peace be upon him and they're asking a
third person who is that traffic
referring to Deuteronomy 18 18 that
prophet from among the Brethren so these
are the three distinct personalities
that the Jews were waiting they asked
the similar question to Jesus in Gospel
of John chapter 1 verse 25 they asked
and the same our user Elijah are you the
Christ are you the Prophet so he says
John the Baptist is the Elijah he says I
am the Christ Jesus and that prophet is
still anonymous is still remaining we
Muslims are informing our Christian
friends that this is referring to that
prophet that is particle Hamid let's go
further in the very words of Jesus peace
be upon him Gospel of John chapter 16
verse 7 now Jesus is saying in the red
letters in the Bible he says
nevertheless I tell you the truth it is
expedient for you that I go away for if
I go not away the comforter will not
come unto you but if I depart I will
send him unto you in this world Jesus is
making a very clear statement to his
disciples he saying I got to go and the
other one needs to come generally the
Christian said this comforter is
referring to the Holy Spirit it was the
Holy Spirit Jesus always calls the Holy
Spirit in the Bible Holy Spirit he never
referred to the Holy Spirit or Holy
Ghost with another title as comforter
why suddenly in this verse Jesus is
saying he will come unless I go not away
he will not come so for example I'm
coming from Australia and you are here
in America brother Eddie I say to you
unless I go not back to Australia the
other Australian speaker will not come
can that Australian speaker be me or you
or our brother you cannot hear with with
us in the studio obviously not because
I'm saying unless I go not back he will
not come so anyone else but not from
this room so when Jesus was saying this
the statement the Holy Spirit was right
then and there between them and Jesus
saying unless I go not away he will not
come to you so it's a very clear
distinction it has to be a new person
and this comforter in the Greek language
is Parakletos Parakletos translated
would mean the one who is praised
the name Prophet Muhammad comes from
that a good hand hand means praise and
Muhammad means the one who is praised so
Parakletos meaning and Muhammad's
meaning are really matching there is
Holy Spirit is not the one who is
praised or the one who praises that's
not the title given to him ever in the
Bible and Parakletos that greek word in
this word is not used for Holy Spirit
ever in the Bible any other time so it
cannot be the Holy Spirit it has to be a
future coming prophet and let's complete
the mid Gospel of John chapter 16 verse
12 to 14 Jesus further says I have yet
many things to say unto you but you
cannot bear them now howbeit when he the
Spirit of Truth shall come he will guide
you into all truth he shall not speak by
himself but all that he shall hear that
shall he speak he will show you things
to come he shall glorify me now Jesus is
giving four amazing characteristics of
this comforter first of all he calls
that he is a spirit of truth once again
Jesus didn't call Holy Ghost once again
Jesus didn't call Holy Spirit he said
spirit of truth so a human soul is a
spirit of truth in the Bible language
second he says that I have more things
to teach you but I can't teach you you
can't accept them but when he comes
we'll bring you all the truth all the
truth how to clean yourself in the
toilet - how to do the country from
cradle to the grave everything is there
in this religion whatever you want to do
friendship family marriage divorce death
whatever because everything is mentioned
very clearly you could come a ruler of
the country what is the punishment what
is the process of Education how do you
deal with all of this is very clearly
mentioned in this in this in the
scripture so Jesus is saying he will
teach you all things to come secondly it
also says that he will not speak by
himself but whatever he shall hear that
shall he speak this is again a human
traffic's character in the entire Bible
the prophets will speak by themselves
whatever they hear they speak the Holy
Spirit on the other hand is one of the
Trinity according to the Christian
belief so does God speak by himself or
does he take command if the Holy Spirit
is God he gives come on he doesn't take
come on so it cannot be the Holy Spirit
it has to be a human prophet and the
human prophet is
I'm not busy about him rippling there
the last thing he says he shall glorify
me the Prophet Muhammad is the only
non-christian prophet who has made it an
article of faith for all his followers
billions to believe in Jesus peace be
upon him and glorify Him
no Muslim is a Muslim we don't take the
name of Jesus unless we add peace be
upon him we glorify his name hope that
makes it very clear as practical Hamlet
is the Prophet Arabic you definitely got
a lot of people sincere people thinking
and we'll be right back with more
Hannity show don't go anywhere
back here on the D show and this was
geared towards more people of people I
mean even even Muslims this only
substantiates and also increases ones
United faith knowing that indeed I mean
even in the Bible he's mentioned we
didn't even mention the Hindu scriptures
Buddhist scriptures he's also this
prophecy is there people can go ahead
and look this up with it but now
somebody who may be like most people
they don't read the Bible some have even
gone away from them because the attorney
doesn't make sense they don't they don't
believe Jesus they believed he was a
messenger more like the Islamic belief
and what really fascinated me is when I
really started to look into problem
hommies life not to talk about all the
scientific facts are in the Quran the
prophecies in the Quran that it's indeed
you know book that's been preserved it's
a CENTAC but then I look back and I look
in his life you know and you see that he
was the most trustworthy the sources
that we have today so he was a upright
honest man who was surrounded by others
who are upright and honest men why would
he lie what's his motive money power
didn't add up he just gave his whole
life to God so what do you say to
somebody who's kind of skeptical to hear
a lot of negativity about him on the
news yeah but they're seeking what do
you say yes hey let's see it take it
this way you know people of different
faiths have different approaches they
have different scriptures to believe in
so if you say Islam and Christianity the
major two monotheistic religions we've
just seen that the Prophet Mohammed is a
prophet according to both Islam and
Christian scriptures let's see some of
the other things people who don't
believe in these scriptures how do we
speak to them about Prophet Mohammed and
the prophecy let's see people who are
atheist or rationalist or humanists
or they just simply believe in no
religion how do we speak to them about
Prophet Muhammad and his prophecies or
his prophet let's just quickly say
Hinduism form for an instance Hinduism
has a book called bhavishya prana which
speaks about the future
it says inhibition prana Parvati
currently at the i3 shlokas five to
eight meaning verses 5 to 8 it says then
will come a man of Malaysia meaning a
foreign person who will who will be from
you know someone who will be on the
desert he will come and his name shall
be Mohammed his followers will have
beers and not shin-bi's like the pundits
the Hindu scholars it says that these
will be the people who will eat all
sorts of four-footed animals the pet
animals if the tamed animals except the
swine these people they will call people
to prayer referring to as an it says
these people will not cleric purify
themselves by dipping into the water but
by fighting against the enemies of God
referring to jihad it further says that
these people will be calm Salman the
Muslims so it is very clear in the Hindu
scriptures there is someone going to
come by the name of Hamid we come in the
lens of desert and he will be the one
who we go for those group over the phase
or Raja of India
you do not have to go to his land he
will come to your land and purify you so
it is very clear for them that there is
a future coming prophet and that his
name his name is Mohammed and they
should also be following that so this is
mentioned even in the Hindu scripture
even in the Buddhist scripture gospel of
Buddha by Karras in page number 217 and
further up it says God my Buddha was
asked by his disciple Ananda what do we
do after you're gone who will teach us
so Buddha says I was not the first
Buddha nor will I be the last after me
there will be another Buddha but the
meaning that enlightened one after me
there will be another Buddha he will be
the one who will guide you he says his
name shall be mightier in Sanskrit which
is in Hindi language or a pali language
met by yah met by amines meta means
great met by Mohammed ah Muhammad's
great Metta ya Muhammad ah would mean
the great person or the great mercy
Mohammed the man who is praised or the
man of mercy Mohammed ah
and in Arabic we have Mohammed Mohammed
ah is pronounced in loose languages
Mohammed the Arabic word Muhammad and
the Hindi word Mohammed Mohammed
Mohammed same pronunciation a little bit
of different because of the language
tape so this is even in the Buddhist
culture there is a Buddha going to come
by the name Maitreya Sanskrit
pronunciation muhammad saaw muhammad
which is not no one else other than
Mohammed well these would be the more
enlightened enlightened what is our
guide you and Buddha says I have got
followers in hundreds even have
followers and how to give us something
for instance the cycle period return
Ashok I was referring to discussing Anna
and now we will see how would we respond
to people who have no faith for example
so encyclopedia britannica secular
sources in volume no 12 a massive detail
from early sources shows that he
referring to Muhammad peace be upon him
was an honest and upright man he was
saying that he's the best land he is an
honest person he's an upright person
let's see what Mahatma Gandhi one of the
most peaceful nonviolent revolutionaries
says in his in a speech which was
recorded in you young India magazine in
1920 he said I was sorry
when I closed the second volume of the
biography of Prophet Mohammed for there
was not more for me to read of the great
life imagine a revolutionary person is
taking inspiration from Prophet Mohammed
so anyone who is fighting for trying to
bring a revolution Prophet Mohammed is
an inspiration for them let's see what
Lamartine a French historian faith in
his book
historic dealer - published from Paris
in the year 1850 for one minima - page
276 he says if greatness of purpose
smallness of means and nest pounding
results are the three criteria to judge
any human genius who could dare compare
any great man in modern history with
muhammad sallallaahu lucidum Sir Bernard
Shaw a vector intellect says in the
middle of World War one and two
recording in the speech in genuine Islam
published from Singapore in the year
1936 volume number one page number eight
he says he Prophet Muhammad must be
called the savior of humanity if he were
to assume the dictatorship of the modern
world he would have sold all its
problems and brought the much needed
peace and
s-something when these modern people
these intellectuals of the society with
no allegiance to the Islamic faith are
attesting to the character and the
greatness of Prophet Muhammad then how
could any rational person reject the
prophethood of Prophet Muhammad I would
like to conclude by saying that if a
person is appreciated and loved by his
followers he is great but imagine a
person who is appreciated even by his
enemies I call that person the greatest
and let's see what Prophet Muhammad is
said by his enemies there is a group
Allah be called Orientalism and one of
the very famous oriental is by the name
w montgomery his job is to abuse and you
know take out mistakes in the character
of Prophet Muhammad he writes in his
book Muhammad at Makkah published from
Oxford in the year 1953 in paidamma 52
he say to assume Muhammad an impostor it
makes more problems than its fault
imagine an enemy of Prophet Muhammad is
saying if I assume Prophet Muhammad as a
false prophet it makes more problems for
us to prove him a false prophet than it
solves to abuse him he goes further and
he says moreover
the only person in the West who is
poorly appreciated is Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him so even the enemy is
agreeing that Prophet Muhammad is an
appreciative person is a great person
has to be actual prophet of God who else
could be matching that prophet in
conclusion I would say as a los lunas
Allah says in the Quran in surah surah
surah number 34 in over 2800 mah
arsalnaka illa rahmatan Lunati bashira
wanna do well echidna acts Arunachala
alla moon and we have not sent you O
Muhammad except to the entire creation
to all human beings Muslims and
non-muslims alike
as a giver of glad tidings and a Warner
but many people are unaware of you last
one on in hamdulillah economy thank you
very much for at a time very beneficial
and to those who really reflect you gave
people a lot to reflect over and for the
sincere person on this is very light may
Allah guide all of us I mean thank you
very much exact of Allah and thank you
for tuning into the Deen show again
subscribe if you haven't already and I
mean it's very just other
it's clear I mean when you look at his
life and you just you scrutinize his
life sincerely if you want to make jokes
make fun and you know you don't do
things sincerely you're going to find
every excuse in the book to turn away
but for the sincere truth seeker
when these facts are presented I mean
they're astonishing and it behooves you
to really get to know this man we
covered the prophecies his name
mentioned he's mentioned by name in the
Bible so for the Christians there what
we already having problems with this
Trinity is being God now they look at
the concept of God in Islam and Islam
obviously just means submission to the
will of God like in the Lord's Prayer
and they look at what Islam calls people
to it just makes sense and you look at
what Muhammad his whole life how it was
lived he proceeded for sick this whole
world and when some people try to bring
up the silly arguments of Joseph Smith
for any of these these people you look
at their lives you cannot compare the
overwhelming amount of evidence that we
have to see that he was indeed I mean he
mentioned the Buddhist scripture the
Hindu scripture Encyclopedia Britannica
you know all these great sources that
just say the most incredible things
about him so it definitely behooves you
to get to know this man while at the
same time really reflecting what's the
purpose of life you're going to find one
way or another you know but when you
look sincerely deep in yourself and you
realize that this life is short I've got
to figure it out and then you have
people such as Jesus Moses Abraham all
of them coming with a proposition for
you you wish you've got alone you do
good deeds you get to Jenner you get to
paradise
well I'm just going to do things my way
and then what you're going to hit a dead
end so do things the right way do a
God's Way and that's why these messages
were sent out of God's love to direct
you to the right way the way to be
successful in this life and the next to
avoid the Hellfire and to get to the
paradise because when death comes it's
too late it'll be too late
and that's why we're doing these program
out of the love so subscribe if you
haven't again already call us you know
what you're almost there you agree that
there's nothing where they worship to
the Creator that happens in Earth
Mohammed Atta's messenger and it should
automatically include Jesus all the
preceding messages call us if you have
some doubt choose one doubt call us
time until then peace be with you